(upbeat music fades)
- All right, before we go
I have one more holiday
themed story to share.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(bright upbeat music)
I love this time of year
because I love the unique ways
each of us celebrate Christmas.
No doubt that applies
to a grandmother from New Jersey.
Crystal and Somerdale has one
of the largest collections
of black Santa Claus in the country.
She started collecting black
Santas nearly 30 years ago
and since then it's
built up her entire home.
Let's get her in here.
Everybody say hello to Crystal.
What's up Crystal?
(audience cheering)
- Hi.
- Hello.
So, you have a very good reason
for loving Christmas so much, right?
- Yes, I do.
My birthday's on Christmas Eve,
so how can I not love Christmas?
- Well, I know a lot of people
that have to share that holiday
and they don't like it.(laughs)
They get trumped,
but I love your optimism about it.
So, can you show us a
few of your favorites?
- Sure, I have a couple.
I have the first one I received
from my late husband.
This was the first one.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
- It's very special to me.
- I love that though.
So, did your late husband
actually get you into this,
like starting the collection?
- Yes.
The first one started,
we had just moved into our home
and we said we weren't
buying Christmas gifts
for each other.
We got the house.
We were out shopping
and I saw this
and it was the first time
I ever seen a Santa Claus
of color.
So, I was elated in the store.
We left the store.
I didn't buy it,
but he surprised me.
He gave it to me for my birthday,
which was Christmas Eve.
So, it worked out well.
(audience applauding)
- Oh, I love that.
I love how it started as well.
Well, it's an awesome collection.
Thank you so much, Crystal,
for sharing with us.
I'm liking your post right now.
(bell chimes)
(audience cheering)
- [Crystal] Thank you.
- All right, well, that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of FriXion
that Go-To Erasable Pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show" want
to celebrate people like you
who share the joy
and magic of the holiday spirit.
So, they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars
just for being cool.
(Crystal gasping)
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- Yeah!
Crystal, have such a great holiday.
Thank you so much, crystal.
Thank you to all our guests.
This our Brendan Fraser,
Sadie Sink, Grinch
and our very own Grumpy Elf.
If not having a great day
y'all, try and change it.